l'université de Versailles Saint-Quentin
en Yveline accueillé depuis le début de
l'après-midi un colloque piloté par une
école d'ingénieur lestaka le thème les
déplacements des personnes à mobilité
réduite bonsoir Pascal Ribon vous êtes
la directrice de cet établissement et
bonsoir à Corentin GGU vous êtes
étudiant en 5e année dans cet
établissement 4e année je vous ai donné
une année de plus en le disant j'avais
un petit doute c'est 4e année
effectivement on va peut-être
s'intéresser principalement déjà au
colloque c'est la première fois qu' un
coloque de cette ampleur qui est
organisée et bien tout juste de se finir
vous êtes satisfaite du du du bilan tout
à fait je suis vraiment très satisfaite
puisque ça ça c'est vraiment déroulé
comme on le souhaitait l'objectif de ce
colloque qu'on a co-organisé avec le CRM
qui est un centre de de de ressources
d'innovation dans le domaine de la
mobilité et du handicap pour trouver des
solutions à la mobilité pour les
personnes en situation de handicap et ce
qu'on souhaitez faire c'est organiser la
rencontre d'un certain nombre d'acteurs
qui travaillent sur ce domaine à la à la
fois de
de de la mobilité mais d'une mobilité en
réponse aux besoins des personnes des
personnes âgées et en attaquant le sujet
sur plein d'angles différents à la fois
sous l'angle technologique mais aussi
sous l'angle médical sous l'angle
sociétal sous l'angle de la façon dont
les dont les gestionnaires de transport
prennent en charge ces questions il y
ait des gens de la RATP de Transdev
voilà donc on a balayé beaucoup de
sujets je crois que trans c'est Transdev
c'est des gestionnaires de bus donc
c'est des c'est une entreprise qui gère
des réseaux de bus dans un certain
nombre de villes de province et des des
réseaux de transport en commun et et
donc je pense que tous ces gens ont ont
pu échanger on a tous pu échanger sur
différentes approches différentes
solutions ce qui pouvait se mettre en
place y compris à l'étranger et pourquoi
associer vos étudiants c'est une école
les staca votre établissement c'est une
école d'ingénieur pourquoi les associer
puis les associer activement aussi parce
qu'on va voir qu'il y a des des
réalisations qui sont nées de cette de
cette association c'est aussi pour pour
ça que vous êtes présent vous allez nous
en parler dans un instant l'estaka c'est
une école qui forme des ingénieurs pour
l'industrie des transports donc les
jeunes qui viennent chez nous ont
vocation à rejoindre à la fois les
industriels mais aussi dans le domaine
des transports des transport collectif
Les les gestionnaires de réseau et à
travailler sur des problématiques
d'innovation technologique pour répondre
aux besoins de mobilité et donc les
faire travailler sur des projets
concrets et sur des solution sur un
domaine qui est un petit peu particulier
qui est celui de la réponse aux besoins
des personnes âgées
c'est à la fois les faire travailler sur
l'innovation mais c'est aussi leur
ouvrir les perspectives quand on pense
véhicule on pense plus on pense à la
voiture on pense qu'à la voiture qui va
vite on pense à la voiture la voiture
interconnectée aujourd'hui et là c'est
sur les faire travailler sur des
mobilités un peu plus douces mais qui
finalement utilise les mêmes
problématiques technologiques et et qui
correspondent à à un domaine en terme de
développement qui va être très important
la la population de plus de 65 ans en
2040 ce sera un quart de la population
France et c'est pas la France c'est pas
celle qui a le la plus grosse population
âgée il faut que les ingénieurs dès
aujourd'hui so formmer et puissent trou
faut trouver des solutions il faut avoir
des idées penser à cette population là
lorsqu'on travaille sur des solutions de
mobilité alors il y a deux projets qui
ont été développés dans ce cadre là une
assistance électrique fauteuil roulant
et puis également un tricycle nous
allons en parler peut-être plus particul
de ce tricycle c'est le projet sur
lequel vous avez travaillé ou ça
consiste en quoi en fait le tricycle
pouvait se plier pour faire pour devenir
un déambulateur et ça permettait aux
personnes à mobilité réduite de pouvoir
se déplacer dans leur maison ou dans le
bus et en fait ça leur permettait de
pouvoir se déplacer dans en intérieur et
de le passer en mode tricycle en
extérieur pour pouvoir aussi se balader
plus facilement et aller peut-être plus
loin que ce que leur capacit physique
leur permettent au niveau distance
comment vous avez travaillé sur ce
projet comment aé l'idée comment on
travaille ensuite à votre échelle dans
dans cette école en fait c'était ce
projet il est né suite au au partenariat
de notre école avec le CRM et c'est le
CRM de là qui nous a qui nous a donné le
sujet en fait à réaliser avec le cahier
des charges c'était difficile c'était
pas évident au début pour vraiment
savoir comment on pouvait bien plier le
vélo pour que ce soit facile à faire
aussi que la personne puisse enjambber
facilement le vélo il y a vraiment
beaucoup de contraintes et c'est
peut-être ça qui a été dur oui à à bien
réfléchir et il y aura peut-être des
choses aussi encore à améliorer vous
pensez que c'est aussi un véritable plus
c'est que de vous pencher sur ces
problématiques sur ces questions là vous
nous l'avez dit qui sont de plus en plus
importantes à l'avenir c'est c'est
nécessaire c'est un plus aussi pour
votre CV vous savez déjà répondre à ses
besoins en tant qu'ingénieur bah ça
c'est vrai que ça ce genre de sujet nous
permettent de réfléchir d'une façon
différente que sur des projets pour
l'industrie de tous les jours mais moi
je pense que c'est quand même des
projets importants parce que dans ce
secteur là il y aura beaucoup de
demandes aussi donc les deux projets qui
ont été développés donc que ce soit le
le tricycle ou l'autre projet dont dont
qu'on a évoqué tout à l'heure
l'assistance électrique fauteuil roulant
ce sont des projets qui pourront se
retrouver ensuite commercialisé c'est
juste un test c'est ça va servir à quoi
ensuite au-delà de l'exercice alors
c'est ce que c'est ce qu'on aimerait
l'idéeil ça a été là on est en phase de
conception le projet a été élaboré il a
été modélisé dans un deuxième temps il
va falloir le fabriquer euh donc pour
l'instant on n' pas encore lancé cette
phase là mais moi je souhaite qu'on
puisse qu'on puisse l' menener au bout
et puis le tester et puis peut-être
derrière déposer un brevet à
commercialiser et puis eu voilà il aura
une suite donné à ces projets qui ont
été présentés ce sera pas tout à fait
c'est vraiment l'intérêt du travail et
au-delà de ça bien évidemment les staca
poursuit ses activités on peut peut-être
préciser on le disait c'est une école
d'ingénieur on y développe pas
uniquement ces ces projets là ces
produits là non non non la Staka c'est
une école c'est une école qui a une
longue histoire puisquelle a été créée
en 1925 c'est une école qui est
spécialisée dans le domaine des
transports automobilees
aéronautique transport ferroviaire
spatial et donc en 5 ans on forme des
jeunes qui vont travailler dans
l'industrie vraiment dans l'industrie
des transport et qui le profil de nos
étudiants c'est que ce sont des jeunes
qui sont passionnés par les par les
objets du transport souvent il rêvent de
voiture depuis tout petit et et donc ça
ça crée une une dynamique particulière
et effectivement à la sortie de l'estaka
ils vont travailler dans l'industrie
transport en en majorité dans la Red et
dans les bureaux d'études de conception
dans l'innovation mais un peu partout
dans le domaine des transports du
marketing jusque jusqu'à la production
en passant par c'était votre cas vous
rêviez des voitures tout petit euh ouais
oui c'est pour ça voilà c'était un bon
exemple vous avez vu le regarder
j'imaginais bien que c'était votre cas
par la suite vous imaginez travailler où
justement vos projets pour vous
justement moi sera peut-être plutôt bah
soit dans le marketing ou la production
je suis pas encore fixé sur le domaine
que j'aimerais travailler très bien et
cette école qui viendra s'installer à
saint-quenttin en Eveline d'ailleurs on
mentioner par que vous avez obtenu le
permis de construire tout à fait il est
affiché on est très content de le voir
afficher sur le sur le terrain donc on
s'installe à la rentrée 2015 sur un
terrain qui est juste en face de la
gare donc sur le bord de l'avenue du pas
du lac et euh ouverture prévue en 2015
et ouverture prévue en septembre 2015
avec nos 1000 étudiants voilà on
investit 50 an en Yveline merci à vous
d'être venu juste à l'issue de ce COC
qui s'est déroulé du coup à 50 ans
nieline mais à l'université puisque vos
locaux bien sûr Nar camp 2015 à 51 en